In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for July 27, on which we commemorate the Holy Great
martyr and healer, Pantelemon.
On the 27th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy and Great martyr, Pantelemon,
and of the blind man, who, healed by him, was slain by the sword.
The Holy and glorious martyr of Christ, Pantelemon, was born in Nicomedia, of a pagan senator, El
Sturgios, and a Christian, Obolia, who gave him the name, Pantoleon.
Placed under Elfrocinius, a well-known physician for his education, he gradually acquired a perfect
knowledge of medicine.
To such an extent that Emperor Galerius Maximian, having noticed his qualities, offered to take
him into the palace as his personal physician.
The young man passed daily before the house where Saint Edmolaus was in hiding.
The Holy Priest, discerning the quality of his soul from his outward appearance, invited
him in one day, and began to teach him that medical science can only provide a very feeble
support to our suffering and mortal nature, and that Christ alone, the one true physician,
has come to bring us salvation with neither medicine nor payment.
His heart, exulting with joy at hearing these words, the young Panteleon began to visit
Saint Edmolaus regularly and was instructed by him in the great mystery of the faith.
One day, on his way back from Elfrocinius, he found a dead child in the road that had
been bitten by a viper.
Reckoning that the moment had come to prove the truth of Edmolaus's promises, he called
on the name of Christ, and the child immediately revived and the reptile perished.
He then ran to Edmolaus's house, and, being filled with joy, asked to receive holy
baptism without delay.
He then remained with the holy elder to rejoice in his teaching, and only went back home on
the eighth day.
To the questions of his concerned father, he replied that he had stayed at the palace to
heal a man close to the emperor.
Still keeping the news of his conversion secret, he worked hard at convincing Astorgeos of
the futility of idol worship.
Sometime later, a blind man was taken to the senator and begged Panteleon to heal him, as
he had vainly used up his whole fortune on other physicians.
Trusting in Christ, who then s forth dwelt in him with power, the young man assured his
astonished father that he would heal him by his master's grace.
He marked the eyes of the blind man with a sign of the cross, calling on Christ.
And the man immediately received the sight, not only of his bodily eyes, but also the eyes
of his soul, realizing that Christ had healed him.
He was baptized by Saint Edmolaus, together with Astorgeos, who very soon fell asleep in
peace.
Panteleon then gave his inheritance away to the poor, freed his slaves, and devoted himself
with redoubled zeal to the care of the sick, of whom he asked no payment, but their belief
in Christ, who came on earth to heal all our ills.
The other physicians of Nicomedia nourished jealous thoughts towards him, and when he had
cared for a Christian who had just been tortured at the Emperor's command, they seized
the opportunity to denounce him to Maximian.
Having listened with sorrow to their complaint against his protege, the Emperor summoned the
man who had been blind and questioned him on the way in which Panteleon had restored his
sight.
Like the man born blind in the gospel, the man replied with simplicity that he had healed
him by calling on the name of Christ, and that this miracle had brought him true light,
that of faith.
The Emperor, in fury, had him beheaded immediately, and sent his men to find Panteleon.
When he had the saint in front of him, he reproached him with having betrayed his trust, and accused
him of having insulted Esculapios and the other gods by his faith in Christ, a man who died
by crucifixion.
The saint replied that faith in God and devotion to him are greater than all the riches and
honor of this vain world, and to support his words he suggested that Maximian put him to
the test.
They therefore brought a paralytic over whom the pagan priests first made their incantations,
accompanied by the saint's mockery.
Their efforts being ineffective, Panteleon raised his prayer to God, and taking the paralytic
by the hand raised him in the name of Christ.
Many of the pagans seeing the man walking and exulting with joy believed in the true God,
while the pagan priests urged the Emperor to put this dangerous rival to death.
When Maximian reminded him of the tortures inflicted shortly before, on Saint Anthimos,
Panteleon replied that, if an old man had shown such courage, then all the more rightly
must the young show themselves valiant under trial.
Their flattery nor threats, being able to break his resolve, the tyrant gave him over
to torture.
Tied to a stake, his sides were lacerated with iron nails, and they then passed flaming torches
over the wounds.
But Christ, appearing to the holy martyr in the form of his spiritual father, Eremolauz, said
to him, fear nothing, my son, for I am with you, and will bring succure to all who suffer
for me.
The tortures were extinguished at once, and the saint's wounds healed.
Then s forth whether he was plunged into burning pitch, or thrown into the sea weighed down
by a heavy stone, the Lord was with him in all his trials, and kept him unhurt.
He was then thrown to the wild beasts, but there again Christ protected him, and the beasts
came to fawn around his feet, licking him tenderly as domestic animals would do.
The Emperor, however, remaining wilder than the irrational animals, ordered that the saint
be tied to a wheel furnished with cutting blades, which they rolled down in sight of the
whole town from a high place.
The Lord intervened miraculously once more.
He freed his servant from his bonds, and the wheel wiped out a great number of pagans on
its way down.
When Maximian asked him the source of this power, and how he had been brought to the Christian
faith, Pantoleon indicated where Ermolaus was hiding, as God had revealed to him that the
time had come for him and his master to confess their faith, and find perfection in martyrdom.
After the glorious deaths of Ermolaus and his companions, the tyrant summoned Pantoleon
before him again, and pretending that the martyrs had submitted, attempted to persuade him
to sacrifice.
The blessed man's only reply was to ask to see them.
When the sovereign replied that he had sent them on a mission to another town, Pantoleon
replied, You have spoken the truth in spite of yourself, you liar, as they are now in
the Jerusalem that is above.
One convinced that he could not overcome Pantoleon's resolution, Maximian ordered that he be
beheaded, and his body burned.
The saint went eagerly to the scaffold outside the town, but, at the moment at which the executioner
raised his sword, it melted like wax in the fire.
Before this miracle, the soldiers who were present confessed the name of Christ.
Pantoleon, however, exhorted them to carry out their duty and raised a last prayer.
A voice from heaven replied, Thou faithful servant, thy desire shall now be fulfilled.
The gates of heaven are open to thee, and thy crown is prepared.
Thou shalt henceforth be the refuge of the despairing, the sequer of those under trial,
the physician of the sick, and the terror of demons, and thy name shall therefore be not
Pantoleon, but Pantelemon.
He bent his neck, and when his head fell, milk flowed from his neck, his body became white
as snow, and the withered olive tree to which he was bound, suddenly burst into leaf, and
brought forth abundant fruit.
The soldiers who had been ordered to burn the saint's remains handed them over to the faithful,
who gave them devout burial on the estate of Amantios Scholasticus, and went to proclaim
the good news in other places.
Ever since then, Saint Pantolemon's relics have never ceased to bring healing and the grace
of Christ, the only physician of soul and body, to all who draw near with devotion.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.